the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones and
house of the dragon update video all
right my friends hbo has finally updated
their website and they've added some new
information that some of you may find
interesting as you all know hbo is
developing their first season of house
of the dragon like i've said before
house of the dragon will be based on
george rr martin's fire and blood vol 1.
we will finally see what happened during
the dance of dragons when house
targaryen nearly drove their own family
into extinction as they fought each
other over the iron throne
now if you have been watching all of my
videos you will already know what actors
have been hired for most of the main
characters in fact we have even seen a
lot of them on set as they have been
filming their scenes for the first
season well in this official
announcement hbo has revealed what
actors will be filling in for some of
the other major characters in house of
the dragon if we look right here at
their official website we can see who
they are
here we have ryan core we also have
jefferson hall who some of you should
remember from game of thrones he was
actually the same actor who portrayed
sir hew of the veil in season one
[Applause]
so you
as you can see i'm busy i'm here on
behalf of lord edward stark
the hand of the king
and the captain of his
then we have david horovich hbo has also
brought in graham mctavish matthew
needham bill patterson and gavin spokes
now let me show you what characters they
will be
ryan core will be sir harwin breakbone
strong harwin is said to be the
strongest man in the seven kingdoms he's
also the eldest son to the master of
laws lionel strong and heir to harrenhal
jefferson hall is lord jason lannister
the lord of casterly rock and the twin
brother to sir thailand de lannister he
also plays tylan lannister a crafty and
calculating politician
david horovich is grand maester melos
he's a voice of reason and trusted
advisor to king viserys graham mcdavish
will be sir harold westerling sir harold
has served in the kingsguard since the
days of king jaehaerys he is a paragorn
of chivalry and honor matthew needham is
larish strong the younger son of master
of laws lionel strong he's brought to
court by his father bill patterson will
be lord lyman beesberry the lord of
honeyholt and master of coin on king
viserys's small council and gavin spokes
is lord lionel strong he's master of
laws for king viserys and the lord of
harrenhal like i said if you have been
watching all of my new videos then you
already knew some of these actors were
in the show we have seen a few of them
on set during some of their scenes now
if you did not see the video i uploaded
late last night i will show you that
right now because i think it's very
interesting george rr martin recently
sat down with ryan condell to discuss
many different things but during the
interview they started discussing house
of the dragon now for those of you that
don't know ryan condell is the
co-creator and showrunner for house of
the dragon in this interview this is
when george rr martin revealed exactly
how many dragons will be in the new show
i think this is very exciting because i
wasn't exactly sure how many we would
see we all remember how game of thrones
left out the direwolves from many
different scenes because of the budget i
was worried hbo might also leave out
some of the dragons for this same reason
but it does sound like we will see just
about every one of them
let me show you what george said i'm
gonna ask one more house of dragon
question and i'll leave you guys alone
which is just like george is there
anything specific that you're the most
excited about just right now as we're
sort of sitting in the
obviously you guys are shooting you've
seen some stuff the scripts exist you
know where it's going obviously you've
been working on this thing for a while
you're
is there something you're really excited
about as as part of this show other than
your own head
[Laughter]
well yes um you know i've always thought
this this was a cool story it's one i
like uh
so i'm i'm looking forward to seeing it
come alive on screen and of course i'm
looking forward to the dragons uh
you know obviously i love i love the
dragons
and we had three of them in uh in game
of thrones but now we got like 17 of
them
and uh hopefully they'll they'll each
have their own personalities they'll be
instantly recognizable uh when you when
you see them the colors and and all of
that uh because the dragons do have uh
do have personalities uh
in the books and it'll be great to see
that come alive and the dragon riders
um that's
that's all uh
that's all pretty cool
well
stay tuned i mean i think uh i think i
think you're gonna be pretty happy
george we're uh we're working very hard
on all that and uh it's really it's it's
it's deeply exciting it's something that
you know i'm very excited about and my
unders my understanding as an uber fan
is they have some kind of a house right
that's what
[Music]
[Music]
you